[Música]
soy joven aún no tengo ni 20 años y como
muchas otras personas en mi misma edad
se espera que tome algunas de las
decisiones más importantes de mi vida
como el que voy a estudiar
para mí esa pregunta nunca fue un
problema pero a mí me encanta discutir
desde que soy pequeño y cuando entré a
secundaria que tenía más o menos 12 años
se organizó un evento en mi escuela
llamado el modelo de las naciones
unidas- común en corto
este evento consiste en que cada
estudiante representa un país para
debatir sobre diferentes problemáticas
de importancia mundial con el fin de
llegar a una solución debatir no es lo
mismo que discutir ya que es un poco más
formal y diplomático pero desde la
primera vez en la que asistí a un mundo
me quede perdidamente enamorada del
evento y claro de debatir seguí llevamos
durante toda la secundaria y
preparatoria y en el camino muchas
personas me comentaron que si me gustaba
tanto mundo seguro que me gustaría
estudiar relaciones internacionales
entonces cuando llegó el momento de
tomar la decisión de que iba a estudiar
ya tenía muy claro que eso era lo que
quería
sin embargo una pregunta igual de
importante que nunca surgían era el
dónde voy a estudiar hoy en día tenemos
la oportunidad de tener más opciones que
nunca en cuanto a dónde vamos a estudiar
la globalización ha hecho posible que
podamos elegir entre cientos de países y
miles de universidades es cierto que
esta es una gran ventaja para nosotros
pues tenemos la posibilidad de disfrutar
de mejor educación y experiencias
multiculturales
pero tener tantas opciones también puede
ser algo abrumador y te puede confundir
eso es lo que me pasó a mí así que les
voy a contar cómo a pesar de que ya así
que voy a estudiar el verdadero desafío
para mí ha sido decidir dónde voy a
estudiar
yo tengo la fortuna de tener la
nacionalidad española así que desde
chiquita quise aprovecharla y decidí que
me ver estudiar a europa cuando llegara
el momento específicamente de decidirme
españa porque ahí tengo familia y la
verdad es que me encanta el país
entonces eso se convirtió en mi sueño
desde chiquita pero realmente se vería
muy lejano porque yo apenas empezando la
secundaria
seis años parecen una eternidad en ese
momento solo veía lo positivo de irme a
estudiar al extranjero la independencia
que tendría las personas nuevas que
podría conocer vivir en un país hermoso
y diferente
pensar en todas las cosas que podrían
venir buenas de esta experiencia pero
fastforward algunos años después cuando
entré a la preparatoria y comenzó a
acercarse el momento de ya tomar la
decisión de donde iba a estudiar me di
cuenta de que wii también hay cosas que
voy a tener que sacrificar o dejar atrás
salirme todo lo que llevo construyendo a
lo largo de mi vida mi relación familiar
mi relación sentimental mis amistades
todo eso se va a quedar aquí me empecé a
preguntar realmente vale la pena que
todo lo que amo y he construido a lo
largo de mi vida se quede atrás para
irme españa'
comencé enfrentarme al miedo que suele
acompañar a una decisión importante el
miedo dejaron una etapa de tu vida atrás
ya la incertidumbre que viene con
empezará otra etapa
yo he vivido toda mi vida en la misma
ciudad con las de esas personas e irme a
un lugar completamente diferente sola
puede ser un tanto aterrador
pero en vez de decir ya aquí me quedo
porque tengo miedo todo lo que venga si
me voy decidí hablar con muchas muchas
personas sobre el tema hablé con mi
familia hablé con mi novio hablé con mis
amigos y hablé con otras personas que ya
han vivido la experiencia de irse a
estudiar al extranjero hablando con
todos ellos me di cuenta de cuatro cosas
muy importantes
lo primero fue que absolutamente nadie
me dijo que no lo hiciera cada persona
con la que platicaban se emocionaba y me
decía que la idea estaba increíble eso
siempre es una buena señal porque quiere
decir que los demás también ven mi plan
como algo que voy a disfrutar y que
puedo hacer
la segunda cosa de la que me di cuenta
es que vale más la pena hacer algo y que
tal vez no te guste que no hacerlo y
quedarte con la duda de qué habría
pasado ya sé suena muy cliché pero es
cierto podría ser que si me voy a españa
no me guste o extraña mi familia y
amigos sin embargo conociendo me es
igual de probable o más probable que me
encante y sea una experiencia que me
cambia la vida
eso para mí vale la pena a pesar del
riesgo las siguientes dos cosas de las
que me di cuenta son en mi opinión las
más importantes y probablemente aplican
a muchos casos
la tercera cosa fue que tenía que tener
en orden mis prioridades como ya dije al
tomar esta decisión pienso en mi familia
la experiencia a mis amigos mi
independencia muchas cosas pero ahorita
en este momento de mi vida que es lo que
se siente bien para mí que me va a ser
más feliz no estoy diciendo que si
decido irme a españa es porque no me
importan en familia y mis amigos o si
decido quedarme no quiere decir que la
experiencia que podría tener en españa
no me haría feliz es muy importante
hacer esto porque al final del día no
eres tú quien va a vivir las
consecuencias de tu decisión y si las
tomas pensando en lo que otros podrían
preferir para ti o en el miedo que te da
lo que pueda pasar no vas a ser feliz
entonces aunque suene lógico siempre hay
que tomar 50 asimismo cuando tomas una
decisión
la cuarta cosa de la que me di cuenta es
que nada es definitivo
yo por alguna razón nunca me había
sentado a pensar en la posibilidad de
que al tomar una decisión es posible
cambiar de opinión o que las cosas no
salgan como lo planeadas esto es algo
que aplica para mi caso pero también
para muchos otros casos
veamos mi caso y para no aburrirlos lo
voy a hacer un poco más dinámico digamos
que yo tengo tres diferentes caminos que
puedo elegir ahorita
camino a decidirme españa estudió mi
carrera de carrera ya me da una beca
para hacer una maestría en inglaterra
holanda da igual acabó mi maestría y
consigo un súper trabajo en una embajada
vivo feliz para siempre viajando y
resolviendo problemas internacionales
camino ve decido quedarme aquí en méxico
estudio la misma carrera pero acá hay
una maestría en la misma universidad en
la que estudie y consigue un trabajo en
una empresa multinacional gracias a mi
trabajo vivo en diferentes lugares y
acabó siendo muy feliz camino se decida
no estudiar la carrera me voy a viajar
por el mundo y trabajo en cada lugar al
que llegó para pagar mi hospedaje y
comida con los lugares increíbles hago
amigos por todos lados tengo muchísimas
experiencias nuevas y decido no
preocuparme por el futuro
los tres caminos suenan bien no bueno
pues nada de eso es cierto
yo no tengo manera de saber qué va a
pasar y no por elegir un camino mi
futuro ya está predeterminado así no
funciona la vida puedo planear lo que
vaya a pasar pero no por tomar un camino
u otro mi vida va a ser mejor o peor
pues no es definitivo que las cosas
vayan a pasar de una manera el ine
españa no quiere decir que me tengo que
quedar allá tal vez estoy en españa un
año y me doy cuenta de que no me encanta
te prefiero estar cerca de mi familia y
amigos que me quiero el otro lado no lo
sé y afortunadamente no tengo por qué
quedarme ahí nadie me forzó a irme y
nadie me va a forzar a quedarme por eso
es muy importante
nominalmente que por más grande o
determinante que sea una decisión nada
es definitivo siempre puedes cambiar de
opinión
por ejemplo hablemos de brad pitt uno de
los actores más famosos de hollywood él
estudió periodismo y diseño gráfico en
la universidad de missouri pero cuando
le faltaban tan solo un par de semanas
para acabar la carrera decidió dejarlo e
irse a los ángeles para dedicarse al
mundo de la actuación por varios meses
solo consiguió algunos trabajos como
actor en comerciales
o como conductor de limusinas su primer
papel fue de extra en una película pero
poco a poco fue consiguiendo papeles
pequeños hasta conseguir su primer papel
importante en la serie dallas desde
entonces su carrera siguió creciendo
hasta que se volvió uno de los actores
más importantes de ahora así que como
pueden ver nada es definitivo
brad pitt cambió de opinión sobre lo que
quería dedicarse y acabó triunfando en
una carrera que realmente le apasionaba
y entonces gracias a estas cuatro cosas
me di cuenta de que si me quiero ir la
verdad es que ha sido un sueño que tengo
desde chica y seguro que voy a vivir
cosas increíbles pero claro que también
va haber cosas difíciles de irme no por
haber tomado esa decisión todo se va a
alinear y va a ser perfecto van haber
desafíos y voy a tener que aprender a
superarnos es parte de la vida
y ahora que siguen
lamentablemente no les puedo decir cómo
acaba mi historia no les puedo decir si
me fue bien o mal si estoy feliz de
haber tomado esa decisión es más ni
siquiera les puedo decir si me voy a
españa o no la incertidumbre de la que
les he estado hablando la estoy viviendo
es posible que todo este debate que
lleva teniendo conmigo misma por más o
menos dos años haya sido en vano todavía
no me admiten en ninguna universidad de
españa pues allá los procesos de
admisión son hasta junio o julio
entonces no sé qué vaya a pasar
todavía tengo miedo de que no me acepten
o de que me acepten y me vayan todavía
tengo dudas pero eso es muy bueno el
tener miedo el tener dudas la
incertidumbre y no está mal
que les puedo decir ahora para que no
creen que todo este rollo podría ser
inútil si no tengo resultados contarles
pues siempre tomen 50 ustedes mismos
piensen en lo que les va a ser felices a
ustedes qué es lo que realmente quieren
y no tomen sus decisiones basándose en
el miedo nunca porque es lo más fácil y
podría privar los de vivir cosas
extraordinarias encuentren que es
importante para ustedes en la vida y
tomen sus decisiones desde ahí tal vez
para mí es importante irme por la
experiencia la independencia y el sueño
que tengo de hacerlo pero tal vez para
alguien más importante quedarse aquí y
cultivar lo que ya han logrado
todo está bien mientras te tomes en
cuenta a ti mismo y recuerdes que como
ya dije nada es definitivo esto siempre
te va a ayudar a tomar una decisión por
más difícil que sea y te va a quitar al
menos un poco del miedo que ésta te
puede estar causando
en cuanto a mí pues si sigo con la
incertidumbre y el miedo de que vaya a
pasar pero al tomarme en cuenta y saber
que siempre puedo cambiar de opinión me
siento más segura de mi decisión y estoy
feliz por eso ya les avisaré qué pasa